desesperanza y desprotección es yadismar
una joven venezolana embarazada
expulsada a Ciudad Juárez
Dónde queda no solo el miércoles 300
venezolanos fueron devueltos desde
Estados Unidos a México se espera que el
número pueda subir a mil cada día esta
nueva tendencia es parte de un acuerdo
entre ambos países
entonces queremos que nos dé una
respuesta estamos aquí en México
quedamos sin plata nos quitaron unos
bolsos este no lo reciben los albergues
andamos por la calle México acepta las
devoluciones a cambio Estados Unidos
aceptará 24.000 venezolanos que cumplan
ciertas condiciones entre ellas llegar
por aire aquellos que crucen de forma
irregular no podrán ser elegidos en el
proceso por este motivo los migrantes no
saben si continuar su travesía y los
refugios están saturados los 40 o los 38
albergues ahorita están al máximo
entonces pasar con toda esta situación o
tomar ese acuerdo vea eso va a ser que
se ponga más fuerte la situación que se
junten más migrantes
pero las dudas No se reducen a México
miles más están en medio del largo viaje
al norte esto es necoclí en Colombia es
el paso previo al tapón del Darién una
peligrosa inmortal selva para acceder a
Panamá y una de las pruebas más duras
para llegar a Estados Unidos
y ya no podemos tener más oportunidad de
poder de entrar a Estados Unidos
las 24.000 visas que ofrecerá el
gobierno de Joe biden son apenas una
gota de agua en el mar solo en los
últimos 11 meses alrededor de 150.000
venezolanos han sido detenidos en la
frontera Sur